good day anime fans
i'm here to tell you about a title that
i just can't get enough of
yep if you've read the title you already
know for today we're going to be talking
about one of my favorite new gen shonen
anime
jiu-jitsu kaizen there are many reasons
why people just can't seem to get enough
of jujutsu kaizen and i hope that i can
introduce some of them to you through
this list here are my top 10 jiu jitsu
kaizen moments and if you haven't been
watching the show yet it would be great
if this list encourages you to give this
title a shot
before we move on to the start of the
list i'd like to encourage you to
subscribe to the channel
each like and subscribe matters and
would really help me a lot together
we'll reach the next subscriber
milestone for this channel onto the show
then
every amazing anime starts off with the
epic beginning and early on
we have this big balls played by yuji as
he takes on the curse
first impressions matter if you're going
to build a convincing protagonist that
you want your viewers to root
for such a thing isn't a problem for
jujutsu kaizen who right off the bat
gives us a pretty nice introduction to
yuji and his background however
heroes are born in crowning moments like
ichigo slicing fishbone with his
newfound powers for yuji
it's in the way he saves megumi in the
introduction to the series completely
outmatched against the curse yuji
nevertheless continues to fight on in as
badass of a manner as an ordinary human
can do
it takes big guts to do what yuji does
in this scene and he ends the fight in
the unorthodox manner of eating the
finger and feels the consequences of
that action talk about bad ass normal
here it's such a strong sequence to end
the first episode that it left many
people wanting more jiu-jitsu kaizen
following that we have panda vs mekamaru
you wouldn't expect a side character
battle to steal the show this much but
for episode 16 i think that's just
what happened i mean this looked like
something taken out of tekken given the
combatants hand-to-hand combat for me is
one of the hardest things in anime to
execute
especially with the level of detail that
would make a battle so immersive and
engaging not a lot of anime relatively
speaking can masterfully deliver on that
and give us a fight with such impact as
this one that's not even talking about
the very moving conclusion in this fight
for what could seem to be a short fight
the animation team sure went out of
their way to make this look amazing
speaking of emotional fights in the
goodwill of antarctic how about the
battle between maki and mai
[Applause]
two siblings separated by the different
yet very similar paths they took that
alone is an ingredient for a very
emotionally charged confrontation
between the twin sisters and it would
all come to head in the goodwill event
arc the pent-up feelings of jealousy and
love finally erupt as they take the
stage for battle
both carrying fatal flaws in their
abilities that caused their dismissal
from the family the fight itself which
marky wins is great but it feels less
impressive compared to the emotional
stakes and impact it gave me in the end
it was my breaking down and confessing
her feelings only to have the other
sibling walk off without repairing the
broken bridge between them it's an act
that powerfully caps off a very touching
and tragic fight i didn't think the
fight would tug on my heartstrings
this much i'm glad that the fight far
exceeded my expectations
[Music]
the mojito scuffles in the series have
given birth to a lot of memorable stuff
what we have here is yuji's rage moment
after having to deal with junpei it's a
moment that sent some shivers down my
spine due to how strong and well done
the acting is in the seed i guess it's
about time jiu jitsu
is enjoying the ranks of battle shonen
with such heart-pounding moments of rage
well the art even made yuji somewhat
resemble gone in his own rage moment you
literally see mahito talk
big game but run tail between his legs
against yuji and tsukuna that's how you
can tell that this is an anime
protagonist who's not to be messed with
i didn't see this coming
and probably a few of you didn't either
this has got to be up there for an
updated top range moments in anime
um
our next moment comes at the end of the
first half of the series the decisive
battle against mahito nanami and yuji
team up in the former second major fight
against mojito this time he's joined by
a very emotional yuji after the
encounter with junpei which i think
deserves a moment of its own the
previous nanami and mahito fight was a
showcase of nanami's powers and meant to
build hype for him this time it's
mojito's turn as we get to see the full
display of his new abilities and they're
exactly as scary as they sound he easily
handles both yuji and nanami at first
and that's before he unveils his domain
expansion it's a thing to be feared
and we just see how desolate it is
luckily for nanami yuji manages to come
in with a save of epic proportions and
forces mojito to retreat the latter
having gotten a taste of sukuna's power
[Music]
foreign
all signs pointed to jiu jitsu isn't
having an epic climax
to wrap everything up and we march
towards our top end with the recent
moment of megumi using domain expansion
one thing i really appreciate with
jujutsu kaizen is how it utilizes its
main characters and gives them a lot of
shining moments we see that trend
improve with the recent bigger hitters
like demon slayer but back in my day it
was usually the main protagonist show
with some moments from maybe the mentor
character i already talked about this
briefly a while ago but here we are
the highlight of the 23rd episode of the
series episode 23 of the anime shows off
megumi busting out his epic domain
expansion
kimira shadowgarden in the battle
against his finger breaker opponent
it's a technique as sinister as it
sounds and it works as a great darker
tie into megumi's growth really amazing
animation and sound direction to this
one and it gives me
chills seeing the technique in action
the thing is just insane and it looks a
hundred times better than it did in the
manga mappa really outdid themselves
this time
right after that amazing moment is
showtime for yuji and nobara towards the
end of the first season we have yuji and
nobara dealing with iso and kichizu
a fight that takes on different twists
and turns the animation quality is
already something we've all come to
expect out of mapa's amazing work for
jiu-jitsu kaizen but can i bring your
attention to the cool twists of the
battle with
reconfiguring the setting and the
combatants typically you'd have these
ensemble fights for the climax but i
like what they did here by separating
the main characters from one another
midway into the fight and reuniting them
we get a better glimpse of what each
fight is capable of before throwing us
their amazing teamwork when they're
together
of course an epic battle like this isn't
complete without the finale of both yuji
and nobara finishing off their
respective opponents in such a cool way
this battle is just as cool with respect
to showing character growth and the
chemistry the main trio have with one
[Music]
[Applause]
another
gojo versus jogo aka the fight that
collectively broke the internet for a
while of course it finds itself so high
on the list as it is in my observation
the episode
that helps skyrocket the series
popularity perhaps it's because being
amazed by mapper's work on the series
and attack on titan is commonplace now
but back then
i think that this is the fight that
finally got everyone's attention as to
what a big hit jujutsu kaizen is shaping
up to be the jovial mentors kiddie
gloves finally come off in this
thrilling battle to the death and
reverse gagashi here finally reveals his
eyes and the true extent of his powers
it's probably one of the best flexes
anyone's ever done in this series as
gojo just destroys his opponent by
showing the full extent of domain
expansion's potential it's crazy that
gojo isn't even trying here
before i compared this moment to the
uber popular demon slayer episode
and i still stand by that statement yep
in terms of the effects the moments had
on their series popularity
this one does pale in comparison but
they still felt the same in putting
their respective shows on the map
second in line is yuji and todor taking
on hanami
throughout the goodwill event arc dodo
has taken on quite the mentor role for
our upstart hero yuji that's why it's
such a joy seeing them work together to
take on the special grade hanami for me
this is one of my favorite moments
because it really shows yuji's growth
throughout the series you could call it
a coming out party for him if you will
that's not to say that dodo was shabby
in this fight as he refuses to take a
backseat to yuji in the battle against
such an incredibly durable and
battle-hungry foe a back-and-forth
battle backed with amazing animation and
evidence of growth is the formula to
create a winning moment i'm sure that
this fight also caught the hearts of
jiu-jitsu kaizen fans worldwide it's
such a thrill trying to see how the
chemistry between
mentor and pupil holds up against a
seemingly unkillable foe the fight is
great and
all but it's just unfortunate that in
terms of visuals and sheer call factor i
think that it had to just be upstaged by
the very next moment on our list
coming in at the top is gojo unleashing
hollow purple
gojo finally joins the battle to put a
climactic end to the goodwill event arc
the whole arc's been a pretty nice take
on standard shonen tournament slash
battle royal and of course
it had to be interrupted by an invasion
of enemy forces when all hope seems lost
who else would you expect then gojo
himself to appear it feels like a
callback to all might arriving at the
end of my hero academia's first part
however i personally think that gojo's
appearance here trumps that one i mean
just look at the guy go to town with his
opponent and combine his techniques
finishing with the epic move hollow
purple such a destructive attack ends up
being the highlight of said episodes so
far what a way to finish off a climactic
battle of an arc and this list is such a
stylish way to win a battle
something the gojo just excels at
how's that for a top 10 moment i'm 100
certain that there are more epic moments
that i just can't sneak into this list
because this anime is just so full of
them for one we also have a lot of
dramatic backstories and some of the
less flashy yet just as important scenes
that make jiu jitsu kaizen such a hot
topic in the anime world today mind
telling me about them on the comment
section below if you consistently like
the content that the channel has been
putting out
may i turn your attention to the various
ways to support vinitube besides
subscribing you can also help vinichu by
checking out my patreon or becoming a
member of the channel whether you pledge
on the patreon or become a member of the
channel you'll gain access to certain
benefits to enhance your experience even
more you should check them out if they
remotely interest you that just about
wraps it up hope you enjoyed the video
as much as i did when making it
stay awesome and i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign